joining us now Texas Senator Ted Cruz
and Kansas Senator Roger Marshall both
down on our Southern border given what's
happening tonight Senator Cruz I'll
start with you
I mean my orcas today his nose was
growing and growing and growing uh this
is all the fault of you and Senator
Marshall for not embracing amnesty
well Laura it's great to be with you
Roger and I are both down here in
Brownsville Texas we're on the southern
border and there is a full-on Invasion
that is unfolding we've seen for two and
a half years the worst illegal
immigration in history six and a half
million people crossing illegally and
I'll tell you as we stand here tonight
hours away from title 42 expiring there
are 22 000 illegal immigrants camped
just south of the Rio Grande preparing
to cross over every day this community
and the entire Southern border is being
swamped it's being overwhelmed Roger and
I met with border patrol agents tonight
we met with the chief we met with the
head of the border patrol Union they
told us that here just just in
Brownsville that they are seeing roughly
a hundred Chinese Nationals a day
Crossing illegally into this country
that they've seen in less than a month
000 Venezuelans cross illegally and what
is so infuriating is what you just said
mayorkas and Biden they're not trying to
stop it they're trying to speed it up
you know we went with the border patrol
agents who were processing these illegal
aliens they now have an app on their
phone they can process an alien in two
minutes and what mayorkas wants to do is
he wants to do it faster he wants six
and a half million to become 10 million
to become 12 12 million to become 20
million and it is an absolute
catastrophe for this country this is an
invasion and Texas is paying the brunt
of the price
well Senator Marshall the LA Times is
reporting tonight that the bite
Administration
has gotten really tough okay by slashing
the amount of time that Asylum Seekers
have to find lawyers before their
crucial first to interview with
immigration officials from 48 hours to
24 hours
Senator Marshall what's that going to do
to you know stem the flood of illegals
crossing our borders that matter
[Music]
well Laura it's not going to matter and
I just want to tell you even on your
angle you you understated the problem
that we're seeing the humanitarian
crisis here I I wish you could sit down
with us and listen to the story of a
Rancher we just met that lives down here
a beautiful wife two young children
before he came here he's teaching his
wife how to load a 410 gauge shotgun and
using the pump action to scare the
people away his uh his Ranch is overran
by these people that are coming across
the border another former Marine from
Afghanistan who said Afghanistan was
safer than southern Texas uh Lord this
is not the America that I grew up in I
number one I would call on secretary
mayorkas to be impeached by the house
he's derelict in in his duties number
two I would ask him or and both of them
President Biden to come into a town hall
was sitting there cruising myself with
the same group of people we just met
with this is absolutely a disaster
humanitarian crisis the number one
threat to our national security is right
here in southern Texas all the way to
Arizona
and I don't like to throw around the
word impeachment casually
but given the enormous change to our
country that is being inflicted on the
American people death destruction crime
overcrowded schools how is this not an
impeachable offense what's going on
it is absolutely an impeachable offense
I would impeach the whole lot of them
but I agree with Roger I would start
with Alejandro mayorcas and I have
called on the House of Representatives
to impeach him and the reason to do this
look we're down here with two others of
our colleagues two other Republican
Senators
there's not a single Democrat down here
Joe Biden's not down here Kamala Harris
is not down here Kareem Jean-Pierre
Pierre who lies about the border every
day she's not down here none of the
Democrat senators are down here AOC is
not in her white pants suit pretending
to cry down here
that the entire strategy of the
Democrats you cannot see the dead bodies
you cannot see the women who've been
sexually assaulted you cannot see the
children brutalized by the cartels and
and defended as Humane or compassionate
and so their strategy is to ignore it
they're counting on the corrupt
corporate media to Pretend This doesn't
exist and the reason we should impeach
Alejandra Majorca to put those facts
before the American people the facts the
Democrats desperately want to hide this
is human slavery
you you may recall about six weeks ago
Alejandro mayorcas testified in front of
the Senate Judiciary Committee I put up
a picture of colored wristbands and I
asked him I said Mr secretary what are
these wristbands and he said I don't
know I have no idea I got to tell you
Laura I was astonished at that answer
because just about every illegal alien
that crosses into this country wears
those wristbands they're color-coded for
how many thousands of dollars they owe
the cartels and as you stand on the
banks of the Rio Grande River you see
hundreds even thousands of those
wristbands and I told him I said Mr
secretary you just told the American
people you're incompetent
and you don't give a damn about doing
your jobs because the color-coded the
teenage boys get sent by the Biden
Administration to every city in America
and they work for the cartels to pay off
the thousands of dollars they owe and
the teenage girls they get trapped in
sex slavery Roger and I were just
visiting with it with a sheriff here in
South Texas who said the average time
for a teenage girl trapped in sex
slavery by the cartels to pay her way
out is 8 to 12 years those wristbands
are modern day leg irons and Joe Biden
and Kamala Harris and the Democrats are
directly responsible for this atrocity
yeah well the pro the problem of getting
rid of my orcas is you're just going to
get another majorcus I think the
impeachment has to be levied against Joe
Biden himself this is this is the Biden
Administration whether he understands
what's going on or not he's the one who
needs to be impeached my orcas are just
going to be replaced by someone just
like him senator Marshall really quickly
respond to that
well I I do think that America has the
opportunity to impeach President Biden
here in less than two years and that's
why we need to be to be doing
um America needs to show up and stop
this nonsense that this is absolutely a
national security issue down here
in crisis it's time for us to stay in
with Texas and secure this border
all right Senators great to see both of
you thank you so much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else